here we go
i'll do this
[Music]
be with you in one moment
alrighty
hope folks are doing well
let me know that you can hear me okay
because
well because i think this is my first
time doing the
uh
youtube live stream
from the new rig
well which is why you have a different
setup um
when i had um
when i had the laptop that i was using
before
it was obviously
mobile so i could set it up over where i
shoot which is over that away
um whereas this
i can't so
now when i stream i stream from the desk
and that's just how we do
so
hard ciders in hand
hope folks are doing well
let's see ms wicked wolf gozer ben donna
carowind hello
anthony crystal homebody lots of folks
jack oh good everyone can hear me
i hope everybody's doing well
i just got back and when i say just got
back i mean 10 minutes ago i just got
back from seeing
venom let there be carnage no i will not
spoil anything in the stream don't worry
i am gonna have to shoot my review right
after this which is why miss wicked wolf
no while i am drinking i am not getting
drunk tonight um because i've got work
to do
once once i'm done with this
um
you're golden also last week i got my
first vr headset best of luck with that
i am the idea of trying vr terrifies me
because i get motion sick
from games as is the idea like knowing
how badly
uh motion sickness tends to hit the
people who try vr yeah no ah that that
would go
very badly very quickly
uh hey bookworm roxy chick cali charles
oh
lots of folks good to see you all
uh
my water is banana milkshake if your
water is yellow high or a plumber or a
doctor
yeah fair enough
is it worth a watch um if you liked the
first venom then yes you should check
out uh let there be carnage
i guess here's the thing
and this is true of both movies i can't
really defend it as a good movie
but i sure have a lot of fun with it
and like i'll probably um elaborate more
on this uh when i shoot my actual review
but
i feel like i'm much more forgiving of
these movies than i might otherwise be
because um
well
because when i first fell in love with
ben
benham venom back in the 90s
um i was i was like 12.
so
you know i i the nostalgia i have for
the character i feel like it puts me in
that mindset and it's
it just makes me much more forgiving
yeah i know the ring light is reflecting
um
hang on maybe if i
if i shift that a little that way
i'm not sure that's worth it
i mean it's still going to reflect it's
a matter of where
i look
um
so doing the best i can
you know new setup and all that
but i i enjoyed let there be carnage i
thought i thought it was fun even though
i i would not call it a good movie
but like both it and the first venom are
fun in an extremely 90s way which
hits the nostalgia that i want out of
these so there you go
double vera tonight watching your stream
and the brit detective show vera see
what i'm doing here
props to you for being able to juggle
that many things at once
i frequently try because you know adhd
but doesn't mean i actually take things
in very well
my thoughts on charlotte's web
i don't know i grew up on the animated
movie never saw the live action one
um
either read the book or the book was
read to us in grade school i can't
remember now i know i knew the movie
first
it's fine
at least the eminem song is better in
this movie i
liked how terrible that song was
venom
venom
so bad
have you watched no time to die no it's
not uh where i am yet it will be come
thursday
i think i probably won't see it until um
until next week though i mean the like
i had to see venom tonight because this
is
um my last night this week uh before my
kiddo uh comes over
because uh
because i have her alternating weekends
and
uh i'm not gonna take her to see no time
to die and she wouldn't want to anyways
so you know i
and i don't i don't want
like it's not like she isn't old enough
to handle herself but i don't like the
idea of just leaving my kid to go and
watch a movie she doesn't give a dang
about makes me feel like a bad parent so
what was your favorite halloween costume
growing up
i don't know
i had a lot of fun doing dracula when i
was young
like real young
i just like that they've not tried to
make an r rated series [ __ ] and just
embrace everything about this is dumb
well they kind of have to since they you
know
they weren't going for the r rating so
if you're not gonna go the full board
gore on it you kind of have to just
accept this is real stupid
eddie
i want to reach his brain
god it's
it's a lot of fun
uh
warner brothers is remaking the lost
boys what are what are your thoughts why
first of all i don't know if i believe
you because you've lied to me before so
i'm not going to google it because i
don't care but just the idea in general
i'll just throw it out there why
what's the point
wish me luck i'm gonna put up my first
youtube video in a week and i'm so
nervous about it best of luck donna i it
i know it feels nerve-wracking
but like
you get used to it for the most part
and look see there's people in the
comments who don't know you
for spewing
bullcrap like i do
and yes i know sometimes you say
something that's actually true but you
know i don't take you seriously that
much anymore you you can only cash that
check so many times
uh
money vera money that's always the
reason for pointless remakes i mean like
that's the reason for anything money's
the reason for original films too it's
just that remakes are a safer bet
like that's one of the things that like
strikes me as a little bit disconnected
from the understanding of hollywood as a
business when people like oh they just
make all these remakes and these sequels
and these franchises to make money they
make everything to make money
and they're going to do the thing that
makes the most money and at present
franchises make more money i say it
present they almost always have
collectively
the the difference is is that it used to
be sequels did not make as much as the
movies that came before but they were
still worth making and you would make
more money on those than you would on
original properties even with dwindling
returns that was part of a video i did a
couple weeks a month ago i can't
remember
but
you know
they make original movies just to make
money too
that's that's
what it is
favorite george carlin bit i don't know
i know way too much of his repertoire um
so it's hard for me to isolate
a single piece it depends on my mood i
tend to favor
um 90s and earlier because
especially like his early stuff i kind
of like
what i think i could distinguish as his
goofy [ __ ] period
and that that would be his term uh as
well because i remember at one point in
the 60s he in a bit he actually said my
job is basically thinking up goofy [ __ ]
and like that
mode was is kind of the stuff i like a
bit better he got
angrier as time went on um and by the
time he he did his last special i i kind
of wasn't connecting with it anymore and
like there were times when it balanced
like in the 90s uh it balanced pretty
well
um and he maintained the balance in like
his his books and whatnot but um
yeah i kind of liked his lighter stuff
to be honest
what's the show you keep posting about
in the community tab
you're probably referring to farscape
where i because i post alerts that the
latest episode of what the frel the
podcast i do with jesse gender
um
reviewing every episode of farscape um
so that's probably the one you're
thinking of fun show check it out it's
on amazon in the us it is anyway i don't
know what service it's on elsewhere
can never be sure
and when have i lied to you i've never
lied to you you know when i'm not
not going down this rabbit hole right
now
i kind of want no time to die to double
down on the stupidity of specter
blowfell revealed he's bond's father and
craig just walks off set
i would laugh sincerely except i hated
spectre so much
i i can't
i just can't
hmm
just curious i think i saw you say
something but for your series in the
break room is no time today going to be
the craig movie no because i was
supposed to be done
with these before this sky falls the
craig movie
um
which i sh which i should do this week
before i do no time to die
ah god i've got a lot going on
farscape looks effing weird it is
that's part of why it's great
for escape is so beautifully odd muppets
in space is a wonderful thing yeah
yeah it's it's
bonkers and i love it i love furscape to
death
excuse me
rewatching salad fingers for the
halloween season have you seen it and
any thoughts i remember seeing bits of
it because like i'm
showing my age i'm i'm a new grounds
veteran from like the uh
the start of the 2000's
so i remember when salad fingers first
started becoming a big thing
i never really got into it it seemed a
little too weird for weirdness's sake um
and it appeared to a kind of
horror fan that i'm not like my i've
talked about this before my interest in
horror uh is largely aesthetic
um and not so much like really
feeling the horror and i certainly don't
like jump scares so like
i like horror
aspects and aesthetics and
um
[Music]
things but i i don't like a lot of the
tropes of horror stories
who's worst mike leather face michael
myers jason or freddy krueger define
worst like are you saying who which one
do i like the least i can't really judge
that i've never seen a um
i've never seen from start to finish a
halloween or a texas chainsaw massacre
movie not for any reason i just haven't
uh
idris elba as the next bond they won't
they're not gonna do he's too old i
don't mean he's too old to do the part
now but i mean they're gonna want to get
at least a decade
out of whoever the heck they hire
they're going to want somebody closer
to 40 than 50.
like if there was a window for idris
alberts closed
again nothing to do with whether or not
he could do the part nothing to do with
whether or not he would be awesome in
the park because he would be but like
franchise management
you won't get as many movies out of him
being able to do the stunts for as long
as you need to have it be worth it
especially with bond which is not a
well-oiled machine it never has been at
a well-oiled machine studio
that could crank a new movie out every
two years like clockwork maybe you'd get
eldris idris albert you get him for
three movies
but bond movies it's a mess every time
the productions are always a disaster
and they always take way longer than
they should for the kind of movie that
it is
uh in terms of like being a big tentpole
thing just because of how many fingers
are in the pie and and how many rights
holders get involved in the thing so
it's always a mess
they'll never they'll never use elba
john m chu said he wanted james corden
to play dr dilloman of the wiki movie
and i was like
john i thought i could trust you i mean
i
i don't care
i don't care
wicked will be a movie it'll be mediocre
the play will still be worth seeing i
don't care
abs how what
when did absinthe become the subject in
uh
in the chat hello i have have i have had
absinthe although i've had the american
absinthe which doesn't have the wartwood
in it
um
i do kind of like it though but then
again i also like licorice so
i've seen the trailer for last night in
soho the new edgar wright film i did uh
that was a week or two ago wasn't it
looked interesting i mean like it's
edgar wright i'll give pretty much
anything he makes a shot at least
because even the movies that he's made
that i don't love are still worth seeing
at least once
scott pilgrim
have you seen wreck and or sequel nope
nope uh
again found footage motion sickness
bad mix
bad bad bad mix
can you see into the future
no
i can see into the past
because there's an amount of time
between when something happens and when
the light reaches my eyes and my brain
processes the information so no i see
into the past as do we all
by the way anyone here good at doing
thumbnails oh no someone who does
ben
get in touch with joel
joel is my thumbnail guy
he is great hit him up on twitter i'll
get you his handle hold on
um
at poorly aged who
p-o-o-r-l-y
a-g-e-d
w-h-o
he is great let him know what you want
he will get back to you and he'll he'll
quote you what he needs in terms of
price like
pay him he deserves to be paid but
send work to joel joel is great
my bro has had the real thing and said
it was quite trippy uh with absinthe
yeah i'm
the idea of tripping is
not one i'm particularly eager to try
i'm not gonna say never but like
i've got enough issues with my own brain
the idea of uh like unlocking or deep
diving into parts of it
i can see that going bad very quickly
did you see the new trailer for encanto
i did
it's interesting
i i feel like it's the kind of pitch
that
is it feels like the kind of movie that
is it is hard to do an elevator pitch on
i uh i'm dog sitting right now so there
is now a dog down here do you want to
see the people what no you're going to
walk away i was i was going to try and
show you a puppy but he wandered off
archie come here buddy
come here
you want to come here
i think the people like to see you
i'm gonna try this hang on
come here bud oh you're rolling around
that's what that's what's up come here
come here
oh
people gonna want to see you yes
yes
let the people see
see this face
don't lick me yes look it's people hi
people hello friend
hello
all right all right here you go
little bugger
so that's archie
uh watch him every now and then
he's a good boy he's a good boy isn't he
yes you use
uh
have you ever been on an acid trip nope
i've never i've never done anything
tripping i've never
had acid i've never done shrooms never
had relapses and again don't really
not eager to try
i'm not really like i feel like
whatever window there was for me to
engage in
drugs
i think i pass it
i just
yeah
not uh not something i'm feeling so much
who's excited to see muppets haunted
mansion
okay funny thing about that brandon is i
was talking with liz
and she she said you know
she didn't know about mobizen mansion
and she said you know they have muppet
christmas carol there really needs to be
a muppet halloween movie i was like ooh
do i have a do i have a surprise for you
and a trailer to show you so that that
was
that was a lot of fun uh to show her
that i'm looking forward to it i don't
have super high expectations but i
expect it to be fun
and uh i expect i will
uh i'll definitely review it after i see
it whether i'll see it right when it
comes out i don't know
it's hard to know these days just with
everything going on when i will get to
things and since i've made the decision
to move
pretty much all the review material that
isn't doctor who
um over to the break room
um and i say that just because like when
new episodes of doctor who started
airing you know i'll put them in the
uh in the main channel but pretty much
everything else is moved to the break
room so like i just
i don't feel the need to jump on it
immediately because i'm not as worried
about
oh my goodness excuse me i'm not as
worried about numbers when things go in
the break room
uh
i'm afraid i don't have twitter does he
have an email or a discord
yes
i can get to
email i
think
see that's the thing i normally talk to
him
through a messenger app that i don't
want to give his information out on
give me a second here
okay i i hope you're writing this down
ben
joel
072002
gmail.com
that's joel's email hit him up
tell him i sent you
offer him money
he's worth it
i finished uh
i finished so i can talk about it now a
couple weeks ago i got to work on the
set of the new witcher prequel oh
i hope you enjoyed that um i haven't
seen any of the witcher stuff
muppets like miz needs to be a thing
already okay jack you need to google
uh or look on youtube sesame street les
mis because that's already a thing
uh any thought on the blair witch
project originals and sequels i never
saw any of them all the way through um
i saw most of the original
i was working at a movie theater at the
time
um but
it uh you know motion sickness again and
it just it it didn't scare me and i
never had any interest in any of the
sequels or spin-offs or anything like
that like i appreciate what it was
and i understand why it took off but
never did anything for me
green mountain cabaret yes yes indeed
working on getting shows put together
again it's still uh still a bit tricky
but
you know hopefully
uh well no i will be performing i'll be
performing
on the
15th 16th what's the day 15th um i'll be
performing not with the cabaret but i
will be performing i gotta nail down my
numbers
for spooky season i recently saw the
1979
salem's lot for the first time i enjoyed
it very
tense dare i say best stephen king
miniseries
um yes even better than it haven't seen
it um
i also haven't seen that version of it
either again like there's there's just a
lot of um
there's a lot of cultural touchstone
stuff that passed me by
uh at the time or i never had reason to
circle around to
so
you know
and i don't feel a particular need to
go back to it
jumping tracks a bit i've been growing
my hair out any tips for keeping it
under control uh conditioner
that's kind of all i've got depends on
the nature of your hair i suppose
i don't know if you remember but i've
been saying for a while uh i'll be
filming my own series soon well soon
finally came and we start production on
saturday
congratulations louis very nice
that is excellent
what are your thoughts on squid game i
am aware it exists
those are my thoughts
ah
oh hey andrew nice to see you too it has
been a while
do you think uh in the spite of her
sequel they might
feature the broadway turn off the dark
spidey
i doubt it if only because well okay
here's what i'll say i wouldn't be
surprised if they reference a broadway
show for spidey they won't feature that
as a spidey because not enough people
will know what the hell
it is or means
um
and like you can do deep cuts but the
problem with the problem with broadway
show
with well deep cut plays in general is
it's not immediately accessible to
people who don't have access to the
theater where it's playing so like they
won't they won't do that
you should have been pennywise on the
remake
no
lovely thought but no
so cruel i'll never get to see vera
perform live wrong continent um you know
there are uh
there are virtual shows i just i've just
never gotten into them
um
[Music]
partly just because i really love the
the being able to feed off the audience
oh geez
john thank you
oh
you get a heart and i actually forgot to
say at the start super chats get you a
heart and my thanks and a guarantee that
i will read your comment and or
question otherwise i do try and keep up
with the chat but make no promises
let me hit you with the idea of an
adaptation of the tempest
where
prospero is
uh
prosper pina antonio is adriana and
ferdinand is veronica
well uh the first thing that comes to
mind is the julie taymor adaptation of
the tempest which did already have a
female prospero uh didn't genderbend
anything else i also heard it wasn't
very good so i never got around to
seeing it um
the tempest
the tempest is an interesting play and
would be one
like here's the thing
so far as i could tell
julie taymor just um
bent the um
the gender for prospero because she
wanted to cast helen mirren and fair
enough for the record that's that's as
good a justification as any
but in my mind
you'd need to really rework some of the
characters rather than just gender swap
them not heavily but enough to account
for the fact that unless you're just
saying this takes place in a completely
gender philip universe where power
dynamics are on their head and women are
in power and men aren't then you should
be doing something with the characters
to account for
the way women at that point in time
would have been allowed or not allowed
to hold power or hold influence or
anything along those lines um i think it
will
require more thorough reworking of the
characters which i would be interesting
to see
if you ever wanted to get into current
gen gaming you should try streaming
games with xbox game pass providing your
internet isn't complete trash my
internet is up and down um and i am
technically current gen now because i i
have a switch and i actually on my rig i
can start playing more recent games um
and will be as well um i'm gonna start
streaming
hades
uh tomorrow
actually
i get that installed um so
uh but like
getting more services and game pass and
i don't know i i i'm
i'm trying to not sink more money into
things that i can help
apparently the rose book novel written
by
rtd a future doctor was described as
tall
bald black and wielding a flaming sword
huh
that's very much i love the idea of the
doctor with the sword i know he's had a
sword
at a few times but um
thoughts on the morbius movie that's
gonna be so bad it's also gonna bomb
like maybe not bomb but it's gonna
underperform uh for the one-two punch of
your average um audience has no idea who
morbius is like you could theoretically
make that argument about venom but the
thing is there's a lot of casual
spider-man fans who know who venom is
because he showed up in like say every
single cartoon iteration of
spider-man ever and multiple video games
or whatever morbius is a deeper cut
he's basically a vampire and i think the
public in general kind of burnt up
vampires i think the public in general
is kind of burnt on jared leto to be
honest
i mean i'm gonna watch it but
i don't
i just don't think it's going to make
anywhere near the returns sony expects
or wants it to it won't come close have
i ever seen uh
always sunny in philadelphia bits and
pieces i
it's really difficult for me to get into
a show or movie or series where i
where everyone involved is a terrible
person and i know for some people that's
actually like the appeal of some of
these things hell it was kind of the
appeal of seinfeld back in the day
but my tolerance for that is
limited
um and it's hard for me to get it's why
i couldn't watch rick and morty well
it's one of two reasons why i couldn't
watch rick and morty um i
hate
dialogue that improvised it really does
great on me and i it
makes me grind my teeth
script your
freaking lines for god's sake
do you remember the bloodshot movie with
the vin diesel interesting fact it was
originally going to be jason david frank
in the main role i'm not sure if i know
who that is
i'm gonna have to google
who that is
jason david
frank
that's all just one person it's not
three people
lame joke
jason
david
frank
who the
heck are you
oh
tommy from power rangers okay
i do know who he is
i don't know what the heck else he's
done
but i i i do know i do know who he is
i always hear that pod question talk
about game pass and how they played some
overlooked games because it was on game
pass it sounds like a genuine cool
service for exploring games it does the
the thing is though for me is that now
that i finally have a rig that can play
decent games and i have a switch i'm not
i'm not needing an outlet for
little-known games i think it's really
good for people like the folks on
podquisition because i listen to that
one too
because they play a lot of games
so they're gonna
they benefit from having something that
will give them access to
lesser-known stuff
i don't necessarily need that because
i'm only just starting to play
you know the known stuff and even with
that i'm kind of skirting along the
edges because i've been playing stuff
like celeste and spirit fairer and i'm
working on dead cells right now so
but my point is i don't need access to
the lesser-known stuff because just the
just skimming the surface of the
publicly known and and
um
you know everyone's aware of stuff is
way more than i have time for so
maybe don't watch my show then all the
characters are just straight-up villains
well okay well here's the thing there's
a difference between a show of nothing
but villains and a show that's nothing
but terrible people because like
i i should clarify
not just terrible because like
friggin breaking bad is about terrible
people um it's something about people
lacking any redeeming features
that was kind of that was kind of my
thing with rick and morty like there is
nothing i like about this it's not that
they're bad people it's not that they're
villains i can work with that heck i
like archer that's about the closest i
come to that kind of thing but like
there has to be something about them
that i like and would want to be around
um at least you know within the confines
of watching them on a show
if there's nothing
if there's no
redeeming
qualities at all i just
i don't want it
um
oh john thank you again my goodness
have a heart
i think some of the same issues at play
when gender swapping the tempest would
be at play and telling the story of
francis gump and jonathan curran
i'm
okay google is my friend
i'm trying to
are you gender swapping things again or
is that a thing i should know
because i'm assuming by
francis gump that's a flip on forrest
gump
jonathan curran
oh would that be instead of jenny
oh yeah cause it'd be johnny
okay
yeah yeah
that's that's the thing about gender
swapping and it's one of the
it's one of the things that i think can
frustrate me because it's it's not
uncommon especially in like community
theater
to gender swap roles either out of
necessity because
it's very common for you to have access
to more female actors than male actors
in a lot of community theater settings
um or you know somebody is you just
they're just going to be better
but
even if you do that which technically
you're not always allowed to do but like
who's checking but what you're
definitely not allowed to do is change
any of the dialogue and some characters
when gender swapped
fundamentally don't work the way as
intended anymore because
the things about their gender or how
their gender is meant to be perceived or
factored into their background is baked
into the character and doesn't translate
when flipped so you do have to be
careful about that and that's not a
reason to not gender flip things but to
do it properly in most cases it requires
some fundamental reworking to account
for things because otherwise it's a
gimmick
um
just listen to the third series of missy
from big finish it's so good i do need
to get back to big finish
uh the first cloverfield flick was
filled with utterly unlikable characters
which is why nobody remembers the
characters from that movie
they remember the monster and if they
were around at the time they remember
the marketing campaign nobody remembers
those characters
[Laughter]
so you kind of made my point for me
ah
i take it playing amnesia wouldn't be
great for motion sickness either i'm
finding it a little overrated myself
well amnesia is an old game at this
point
and it's kind of the streamer cliche
you know to play a jump scary kind of
like that in five nights at freddy's to
overreact at the camera for i don't
really want to do that besides not
really my genre like to a 2d
2d keeps me from getting motion sick
the hill i'm willing to die on cats is
better than the phantom of the opera you
go ahead and you you have that hill all
to yourself
fair point though arguably celeste dead
cells and spirit fair are less known i
mean they're less known in the sense
that um
you know i'm i'm i'm looking for 2d
games which are going to be smaller
productions because all the big studios
are doing these massive 3d games which
until until i get my proverbial sea legs
again i just i can't play
best and worst halloween memories ha
no
the question is fine but no
sorry
like asking for my best and worst
memories of something just it feels
like i don't know
that's that's that's feels personal
not mad at you for asking it's fine
i vomited when i watched cloverfield so
did i
actually um
i i had to run out of the theater and i
threw up in a garbage can
and uh when i came back i watched most
of it with my eyes closed
and had my at the time fiance
um
tell me what happened in the bits where
i couldn't watch
oh boy that movie
did you ever get through your sensei
watch with your partner nope we're still
chipping away at it very gradually
because we have to we have to a both be
in the mood and be um
be able to devote full attention because
it's not uncommon for when we're
together one or the other of us kind of
has work to do so what we put on is
something that can be a background
feature for you know for us both to
watch but like doesn't require undivided
attention sense8 kind of does
um and since we've gotten back into the
school year liz frequently has stuff
that she still needs to do so we're
still only about halfway through the
first season we will get back to it
i've always wanted to get into big
finish proper i've listened to most of
the spotify stuff but the cost is too
prohibitive subscription services are
your friend big finish yeah agreed big
finish is
prohibitively expensive um although like
i do appreciate how much they've put up
on spotify what are your thoughts on
five nights at freddy's um scott cawthon
is a dick
that is my thought
and i have no further thought
um have you ever pulled a charlie horse
before oh yeah oh yeah i've woken up and
gotten them before which is awful like
you you find yourself
just going rigid or thrashing in bed
because like ah
oh
not fun
i i have had that it's
it's not ideal
why do you think there are no doctor who
games there are
but they tend to be uh smaller adventure
type games like i played the lonely
assassins
um
so
um you know they're out there but if
you're asking me why there isn't a big
budget aaa
doctor who game it's because the big
budget games
are combat focused
and you can't have combat and doctor who
without betraying the character
and even in terms of like non-combat
stuff like platforming
that's not really what he's about either
i think
doc who the doctor is doesn't translate
to the kinds of games that big budget
game studios make i just i don't think
it does at all
i pulled one on sunday in my in my left
calf ooh
apologies
uh obvious uh
sorry i had something oh okay retracted
sorry i was in the middle of reading a
comment that got retracted um
yeah
if you watch brooklyn nine-nine all the
way through i have not i need to go back
i've seen like the first three or four
seasons
completely i kept meaning to like go
back and catch up and i just didn't
now doctor who puzzle game the answer is
always the sonic screwdriver
yeah
yeah like
doctor who just doesn't gamify well
um
because what are the things the doctor
does
explore
and
like put two and two together like so
you you can't standardize the kind of
thought process he goes through with the
point-and-click thing i mean you could
do it as an adventure game but it's
going to feel
static and lack the energy because the
problem with those kinds of games is
they are slow and methodical and doctor
who actually has a lot of energy but
it's not energy that translates into
platforming or combat which is how video
games do high energy it they just really
aren't very compatible
the fact that paul has the blue eyes in
the trailer implies the new dune movie
goes pretty far into the book
i'm working on the book right now um
[Music]
need to have it done before the new
movie comes out um on a scale of one to
ten how hard do you think you are what
you mean right now
or looking at my best
i'm not gonna answer that either way but
do you have any big finish that your
patreons voted on if not i recommend
doctor who and the pirates as always
i have some big finish that i i have but
have not gotten to um because
unfortunately when i got my new car it
doesn't have a cd player and that's
where i used to listen to big finish on
commutes
um
but i can't because there isn't a cd
player in the car so i need to like i
need to like rip the audio and put on
something that i can
um
that i can listen to because i've got
like i've got the ninth doctor box set i
have jago on lightfoot
um
i i've got i've got some other stuff i
can't even
remember right now um which i which i
want to listen to
but you know it's a pain in the butt
um obviously i don't think
uh you'd ever make them now but what
stopped your ranking reviews on
buffy and angel i was always interested
to see one on seasons i just kept
pushing it back for other stuff
um oh check the discord yes carowind i
will do that in just a moment just gonna
answer this question um
so like
more buffy and angel related stuff was
something i always intended to come back
to i definitely really wanted to do a
deep dive on why i think the
season five finale for angel is one of
the best series finales in television
history but
like at this point i just don't wanna
but i just kept pushing it back because
i
foolishly thought there would always be
time to do it later
that plus like honestly the the buffy
related stuff didn't get the highest
views so that was part of why i kept
pushing it back if i had an idea that i
thought would get better views i'd just
do that and i kept pushing it back and
back and back and back
i'm gonna see the internals yeah of
course all right i gotta check the
discord
so back in a minute folks reminder the
council of geeks discord is a patreon
exclusive perk
i'm not sl i'm not clearing my words
what are you talking about is a patreon
uh
exclusive perk at the two dollar support
uh level
that ain't too much i don't think just
saying anyways let's see what i got
random live stream question you are
challenged to a duel to the death over a
matter of honor but the choice of weapon
is yours what weapon do you choose
choices are mace crossbow or scythe
i would
probably favor a mace it would come down
to a mace or a crossbow scythe is out
because they're cumbersome as hell and
like let's be honest a scythe as a
weapon is a retrofit
they're they're not very practical as
weapons they're slow and they're heavy
um
so i i wouldn't favor the scythe at all
that's out
the crossbow on the mace here's the
thing that it comes down to
the crossbow is going to get the first
shot off whoever has that
but if you miss
and like it's a true accurate
traditional crossbow not like some weird
steampunk
auto reload kind of nonsense
then
you are not going to get a second shot
off before the person with the mace
gets up to you and bashes your head in
so
i'm kind of inclined to take my chances
on being able to dodge that first shot
or that that first shot with the
crossbow is gonna hit me somewhere
that won't slow me down enough to stop
me from stoving the person's head in
with the mace
i thought about that
probably way more than i should have
um moving on to the next question
i think that the people wishing that
davey's bringing back a previous doctor
tenant mostly yeah it is mostly tenant
are doing a disservice to the show
however would you be interested in a
limited series exploring how the
metacrisis doctor is dealing with aging
no regeneration and living his life as
another human on earth
um
no but
i would be up for the metacrisis doctor
and rose showing up in a anniversary
special or a multi-doctor story down the
line
i'd be game for that to touch base but
like extended suit no because i think
even
making the distinction that this is the
meta doctor not the normal doctor i i
think you'd still run into the same
splitting the fandom issues that i
talked to that i've talked about before
um but i i'm i don't have a problem with
checking in on them on a one-off basis
and by one if i don't mean limited
series i mean one-off
uh and one more
have you watched sex education on
netflix i
have
a knot
i
try to remember i think i saw trailers
for it a while back
i just i don't know i kind of shrugged
it off
uh
i'll probably come back to the discord
in a bit because i can see that people
are typing
but i'm not gonna sit here and wait for
the things to pop up so
carowind remind me to um
to swing back to that
um
let's see here
brian l thank you very much
you make me wish i were gay
i know it was meant as a compliment
but my
thing about that is that
assuming that the name brian
is for a masculine identifying person
which is a presumption on my part
granted
um
that means that if you wish
that i make you wish you were gay
implies that you wish you
like
that your natural inclinations lean you
my way but unfortunately that means you
perceive me as male
which
not ideal
i'm not gonna be insulted by it but like
i don't use the male pronouns anymore
and my
days of feeling masculine are few and
far between at this point so i know you
meant well i i i genuinely do and i'm
not trying to
i'm not trying to make a thing uh did
you see beverly bitchy's latest video on
bisexuality in media i saw that it was
up i haven't watched it yet
do you think the ruth doctors the
director from the parallel universe and
the time child is her story i don't know
i'm i'm not in the mood to speculate
about the timeless child right now
i'm really not am i late i thought the
start of the date no may get started
well normally it starts at seven but as
carowind has just pointed out started a
little late because it just got home
from seeing venom let there be carnage
i'm sorry let there be
carnage
because
this this is what you need to know
about that movie
it's the kind of movie where every time
someone says the word
carnage
they pause just before they say
carnage
even before it's the guy's
name
oh
my goodness
uh
there there was that clip that went
viral on dick on tick tock
dick talk
um
what of me which one
was it the one where i said um
because i'm genderfluid no matter how
you identify if you're attracted to me
you're a little bit gay
fair
fair
um
conversation we are having at uni today
what older video games like ps2 would
you like to see remastered okay
allow me to knock that back
but the fact that ps2 counts as older
and like i know number of years it does
but like
to me older games is 16-bit 8-bit and
like oh god
um
i don't know most of the ones that i
would think would benefit from a
remaster have already been remastered
like i know shadow of colossus got
remastered
um
pretty sure that all the kingdom hearts
have been remastered
the god of wars have been remastered
like that's the thing i don't know
um
what hasn't
been
remastered already because i feel like
most of most of the answers that i would
give already have
i think people who are wishing for nine
and or ten to come back or confusing
celebration of the past with regression
bringing ten back would feel like going
back to set a progression yes
yes i agree
which big finish audio story would you
like to see man into a live action
episode or series doesn't have to
do a doctor who audio drama i haven't
uh i haven't listened to big finish
outside of doctor who related stuff and
based off the doctor who stuff that i
really like um
none of it because the stuff that i
really like takes really good advantage
of the audio medium and
i think it's best suited there
um the things you would have to do to
make it work you know could be done
um it has been done
like elements of spare parts were folded
into
um
the world enough in time and elements of
jubilee were folded into daleks so like
there's stuff like that but i don't know
i don't know
um
i guess i play i guess the missy stuff
missy series that could work
are you dressing up for halloween if so
what are you going as uh probably and i
don't know i'll make it up as i go
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
ps2 was like my early childhood yeah and
that makes me feel old
ps2 was your early childhood
i was out of college and
living
as a quote-unquote adult
uh
that uh
by the time i had a ps2 so if that was
your early childhood
if they want to bring david tennant back
they could make him a pre-heart no
doctor give him a completely different
personality no
just don't do it
no
even as a troll don't do that i never
played silent hill 2.
where am i bad i was thinking of that
clip from the other show where everyone
was reacting to that dude's
unit and you said you'd seen bigger oh
that one
yes
yes yes that is true
what are your thoughts on anastasia
it's
it's kind of funny to me how many people
misremember that as being a disney movie
given that it was such a naked attempt
by don bluth to
make a disney movie
that he now kind of isn't even credited
for it in a lot of people's memory
now i want a chrono trigger remake on
the same level as the final fantasy 7
remake why
why
like
final fantasy 7 i get
because final fantasy vii even if only
visually was early polygonal and early
polygonal looked like crap
i'm sorry it just did
16 bit still looks good
it's wonderful and charming and like you
could smooth it out so it looks more
traditionally 2d animated i guess but
other than that what is there to gain
no
since it is october finally which
character do do you see yourself as a
nightmare before christmas okay
when you say see myself as do you mean
like
most relate to in general as a person or
would want to portray
because you know
jack's songs are in my range
so i could actually do jack
that would be fun
um
[Music]
only dust and a plaque
that reads here lies poor
old jack
a little low on that bit but
as far as like who i actually connect
with
uh
honestly
probably santa
i gotta feel like the world keeps
barging in and screwing up my day and
i'm just left going will you stop
messing with everything
[Laughter]
i remember the first nintendo i've still
got my original nintendo that's oh boy
it's in the attic
you want to feel a little shrek came out
20 years ago yeah i know
i know
did you ever play leisure suit larry or
space quest games no i wasn't really
doing computer gaming at that point i
was doing
i was doing
console
words why can't i think
words
anyway um okay going back to the all
right so the
the comments went up in the
discord so who would you rather have
back for a multi-doctor story
ecclestone or mcgann oh
[Music]
oh
dang
if i can only have one
i'm gonna go with mcgann because
i feel like his proper justice in
in tv is still just that seven minutes
short
and he deserves more as much as i would
love to see eccleston back
he had his full series and was great in
it and
i would go with mcgann out of those
have you heard of the movie infinitely
polar bear i recommend it if you haven't
i have not
nope that no
never heard of that not a clue what it
is
um
so yeah i have no idea what that is i
came out as a trans girl this week oh
yay still in the process of telling all
family and building a game plan
uh but this has been a long time coming
in i'm really excited for the road ahead
oh that's wonderful
i'm really happy for you and like i
i wish coming out
would be
something that you only have to do once
it is something that you have to do over
and over and over and over again
um you know as you come out to family
and then friends and co-workers and
social media and
you know then you encounter people who
you know knew you before who
who haven't found out yet and you have
to feel like you have to come out again
i
i know it's a lot but
congratulations
i'm very happy for you
um you should dress up as beetlejuice
for halloween i do not have the money to
get new outfits so whatever i do
which will probably involve the horns
that i showed off on tick tock not too
long ago because those are new and shiny
um
i i can't afford new outfits
so like
that's that's not a thing right now
obviously we don't want past doctor back
for a full series but what if rtd
decided to bring back mcgann
depends on how he intends to use him
i would love to see mcgann back for the
for the 60th
but you know
i'm not going to hold my breath for it
you once said you dislike damian as a
character i wonder if you still feel the
same way for me he has cool aspects like
his relationship with dick here's the
thing
it it's always well first of all
heart thank you a new type jb lee um
here's the thing is that i can only
go by
the things with damien that i've seen
and or read which isn't a lot and
i can't dispute when people tell me oh
but this story arc or in the last few
years damien has gotten good in the
comics or whatever
that may well be true
but that's not what i've taken in of
damian what i've taken in of damien
is
a handful of his early-ish comic book
stuff
and his representation in the dc
animated movies where he
needed to
[Music]
lose the power of speech if not just die
i really hated him he was
horrible he was a terrible character and
i kept making him the focus of freaking
everything
really hate him
i love tennant but i think we saw
everything uh
his version of the doctor could offer
i'm slightly more open to eccleston
since we saw so little but even then it
should be a few specials at most yeah
agreed on that
would your top mcu villains list be
different now any new entries no i mean
um
i cannot remember
how he was named
in the movie but the the the villain
from
from chongqi
probably would muscle his way on there
at this point
um i
it's gonna have to wait until we see the
new ant-man where he's gonna show up
again but there's like
uh provisionally
a space for kang
which i never thought i'd say kang is a
terrible character in the comics so go
figure that
um
but yeah there's there's been a little
shifting
the damian hate is giving me life he's
just so awful
awful awful awful
head kittens that's an adorable name
head kittens thank you so much you get a
heart love to all trans non-binary and
genderqueer comrades yes
love and solidarity
um
i think we are going to wrap it up
relatively soon when woo is his name
thank you john
um let's see
if there's a roger and hammerstein's
cinderella broadway revival you should
play the fairy godmother
people like there were people who were
saying that i should
like cosplay the fairy godmother from
shrek which i don't know how to take
that or not
nick briggs does a great job but do you
think more than one dalek voice actor
would work better
no
i don't
i don't know what the point would be he
does a good enough job distinguishing
them as much as they need to be
distinguished
and i don't think there's enough
nuance to a like character that
you'd get any benefit from another voice
actor
i mean it's not it's not an
uninteresting question but like i don't
know what you'd gain from that
we are going to wrap it up soon
um would you follow any content creator
who was almost completely different
media exposure to you which basically
all you do and have never watched who or
read dc i mean
there are some like i
heck i've been watching
uh james stephanie sterling for years
and i have not been playing current
generation video games
for a decade
so
yeah no i get it i get it
um
another ant-man i love paul rudd but no
see like i'm not nearly as in love with
paul rudd as
everybody else is and i really didn't
like ant-man and the wasp my interest
now is completely on the back of kang
and i want to see what they do with them
favorite mcgahn audio you've heard uh
probably times of midnight
uh
maybe third after the usual times of
midnight
and scurzo i still haven't listened to
scurzo um trying to think what else
i need to listen to more of his
actually because i'm now i'm drawing a
blank
uh
thanks i'm going to steal the dalek
voice argument because i've got a friend
who won't shut the hell up about it
uh oh new type jb lee thank you again
what are your thoughts on 80s doctor who
do you think the era is unfairly too
hated i think there's some cool stories
in that decade oh yeah it's definitely
overhated
like there's some rough stuff sex doctor
especially but like there's some really
good especially seventh doctor stuff in
the 80s yeah
yeah
i think i think it's just overly
maligned because it was the era that
ended the show so i think it's by
association in some ways uh i need to
try and wrap this up i've said that like
four times now now it could be reason
that tenant would be good for the 60th
given he is one of the most known
versions of the character in the current
doctor and the special will be brand new
yeah like um
it's hard to know where things should
go moving forward in terms of all that
would mcgann series work if the current
doctor telling a story is a series of
flash no it's not about framing just
don't
do it
i've given my reasons why i don't think
it's a good idea and those reasons don't
vanish because of the way that you
lend context to it
i've said this before
narratively justifying a thing doesn't
suddenly make something that doesn't
work work
my issues remain
watch the shrek broadway show on dvd
sadly they use the teasler in relation
to the wolf
really
that i had not heard
ew
ew
what do you think of lost episodes being
remade as modern who ah
i'm not sure they translate well like
the the fundamental storytelling of the
errors is too different at this point
very 10 minutes stops
thank you for keeping me in line carolyn
i appreciate that
because yes i do i do have i do have
work to do
um
recently rewatched remembrance of the
daleks i weirdly never realized how
racist a lot of the characters were
yeah
yeah i i love tombs of the cybermen
a lot
but
there's problems with it
and you know they're there and other
things as well
but
okay i am i am gonna wrap it up
thank you everybody for joining me
um thank you for
oh my god now i've got hiccups thank you
for the super chats thank you for the
questions thank you for your time and
your
love and your support and all of it i
appreciate it greatly
i hope that all of you have a great
uh
rest of the week
go home barry you're drunk
oh god
i'm not drunk and i'm already home but
anyways
thank you very much
take care of yourself be well
be safe
and be kind
and uh until next time